I didn't obviously forward to I would
love to be able to the program okay so
thanks everyone for coming
thanks for invitations so I would like
to tell you about something about our
our results and this is called a lower
bound for elimination by a regularity or
we can do and this is actually during
work miss our Karev Papa died about go
dark my student boomer F and shag Nick
Cooper I who was a student of our tariff
at the time so what is this about
actually so this is a this is in the
context of actually what sometimes
people actually called direct some
questions and in particle direct some
questions in communication so we will
have a communication program we will
have some function f and we have Alice
and Bob and Alice is going to get like a
strings X 1 up to X K and Bop is going
to get those ok stinks y1 up to Y K and
these things are actually from domain 0
1 to the N
and there is some function actually F
which is basically the division function
so it's a shift from domain 0 1 to the N
and we go on to the end into say 0 1
it's a this is standard but the
difference is that we actually do have
instead of actually having like one
instance of the problem Alice and Bob
actually somehow should solve this F on
all pairs of these instances not all
pairs but actually unlike on x1 y1 x2 y2
s there are so you just put them like
this so if so there are actually
multiple questions accelerated to this
program and so one one of one kind of
the ultimate one is you just want to
output everything so you want to
actually output f of x1 y1 f of X 2 y 2
etc up to f of X K Y K and the question
is how much communication does this need
does it actually do you need to actually
K times as much communication as if you
just have single F that's basically the
question and there's a generation 2
circuit level bounds and it was actually
introduced like long time back and ask
correct mind reader's annex you looked
at it and there are actually some known
some some examples very actually you can
say if and there are some there are some
partial results on this so this is
actually this is not what's what we are
going to be interested in you're
actually going to be interested in in
actually somehow weakening of this
program and that's actually the
following type of weakening so let's say
it's a program which is called
elimination and I will actually try to
tell you where it comes from originally
but it's much weaker actually a question
so so so you get again like a distance
is X 1 up to X K and Y by map up to YK
and your goal is to output some string Z
which is actually not equal to f of x1
y1 up to f of X K Y K so basically wanna
output some string which which actually
differs from one of these function
values and so that that's that's
elimination so this program actually was
studied in a complexity that were
actually for problems like like in
basically structural complexity like for
problems like SOT so you've got like
several sub instances and you should
that means you get some several formulas
and you should actually point out to one
which which actually say it's not
satisfied or which one is satisfiable
and people study this a lot in ATS and
you can see that this program is
actually much easier than the direct sum
question because you don't need to solve
all the instances easy way to solve this
problem is you solve the first instance
and if it's actually you get a solution
and then you just you just basically you
just basically flip the answer and
that's that gives you that gives you a
valid output for elimination
so elimination a section of the function
it's actually duration so you can
actually output anything which which
fits this requirement and there are
actually some some other some other
actually like you know beginning or
strengthening of this program so one of
them is actually so called choose
program where where what you can do is
actually a like Alice and Bob can kind
of pick whatever instance they want to
solve and they solve that instance so
they can actually they can pick
basically semi and output I F X I Y I
and there are actually there is another
one which actually people look at in
that's actually called agreement and in
in the agreement case what you are a
promised is that either all instances
are actually negative or all our
positive and if you just distinguish
which one is the case and if you get
some mixed mixed input then it doesn't
matter what you all so basically
requirement is only on consistent inputs
so so you should output educate answer
over there all I or F X I Y I are equal
why do all of them are equal and if yes
whether they are one should shoot arms
but all this
so so you can see that these these
programs actually have various various
complexities and the question is if I
give you if I give you actually several
instances like this whether you can
actually do something better than
actually picking one of the instances
and solve it so that's that's the
question we are we are actually looking
at and if you look on what were the
programs on these programs it's clear
that actually some problems are easier
than others so for example if you can
solve efficiently choose then you can
solve efficient of the elimination
because if you if you run protocol for
choose then you get basically output I
if X I Y I and then you can just
actually negate that output and output
some fill in the rest so one thing to
realize so what we will be actually
interested in we will be interested in
in a probablistic probablistic protocol
so it will be interested in
probabilistic communication complexity
so we will actually our error and if you
actually hello-hello a randomized
randomized competition then it's it's
clear that actually the error you should
actually put some requirement on the
error so so you'll use actually
randomized communication
so you want to use randomized
communication and if I allow you to use
randomized communication then of course
there is a trigger protocol
you basically just don't look on
anything I just output a random string
and under that under that actually model
if you well it's easy to basically be
correct this such a general protocol is
going to be correct with this
probability basically 1 minus 2 to the
minus K so so such a protocol basically
is stable so so you should basically you
know so you should you should basically
require for this to be interesting you
should require that the error is
actually much less than to be minus K
maybe not much less but it should be
better to 3 minus K rice it's trivial
right sorry now I'm singing of
elimination ok so so from now on I am
actually going to focus on elimination
so so if you saw since actually
elimination is harder than you know this
program or this program because we can
we can reduce it to 0 of these our goal
will be actually to prove a lot of
bounds for elimination so that that
means that if we prove it for
elimination then then we will actually
get also lower bounds for choose and
agreement so the goal our goal will be
to actually show that basically these
problems for large parts of functions
you basically have to you have to
actually solve at least one of the
instances that's kind of so so we need
so we need actually a really small error
and otherwise the problem is trivial and
then the question is what can you do one
thing actually so we don't necessarily
have to actually require that actually
both parties learn the output because
the output if the case actually large
then then just communicating the output
could be actually expensive although we
will actually consider like public point
public Cohen protocol so then then it
could actually it may not be
if he if he considered public coenen
actually the protocol which I said
actually both parties would learn the
output because they would actually use
the same random random bits to actually
solve the problem so can you actually do
anything better in in this protocol
sorry in this model and it turns out
that actually you can and you can do
actually slightly better than actually
just just actually solving one of the
instances and you can solve at least
tiny bit and that's actually going to be
in the case when and actually one party
will lend output so we say we kind of
relax the requirement that all parties
actually learn the output and then we
can do slightly better in particle if
you take any function f on any bit
output and okay you say take you take K
which is not too big say less than M
then we can say we can solve this
elimination of F 2d case will compress
or elimination for this function f using
n minus half log K bits so this is
actually slightly better than just
actually the table upper bound which
would be actually n bit so so that's
what we can do and the error is going to
be as as required is going to be less
than T to the minus King so what's the
protocol so this protocol is actually
from a paper by [ __ ] wine rep and other
people be moving that
and so let me actually explain you how
the protocol works so so you can
actually do a little bit so here is a
yes here is what you can do
so let's actually Alice and Alice and
Bob and they'll actually share some
random strings are one hard to etc of
flankton and here is how they proceed
so actually always looks on her
instances and checks whether actually
she got she got enough different
instances so if if all the instances
would be the same then they will do
something else but if she got actually
at least square root of K distinct
inputs then what she's going to do is
actually she is going to look into this
R 1 R 2 etc and she is actually going to
check whether one of her inputs actually
appear in that list so she is actually
going to use this randomness as as
basically a list of instances so she
will actually look for the first J which
actually corresponds to the first J
among these things are J which
corresponds to one of our inputs and if
she found such an input then she
actually sends this this index J to Bob
and what Bob does then Bob actually
computes basically F this of RJ at X 1
so it should be actually other way
around and rj x 2 rj x k and just
outputs negation for each of these so
you can see that actually since rj was
actually or actually sorry this should
be
so you can see that actually since since
actually RJ was one of those strings of
LA's actually they are going to output a
valid output for for for the elimination
program and how much do they communicate
well they need to communicate basically
n minus half log K bits actually so in
this setup basically the output
correctly if there is such J if there is
no such a they just actually flip random
bits and they output random it may be
there is some chance but actually none
of the RJ's actually matches input of
Alice and then they are out of luck and
then they just output random them the
situation could be reversed so actually
Bob could have a lot of different a lot
of different instances if that's the
case then they just do the same but they
just reverse Allison ball it's the same
same scenario so so the last remaining
case is actually if actually none of
them has actually a lot of different
instances but if that happens then that
means that they have lot of basically
instance is the same so in particle
Alice has square root of k instances
which are all the same and then but but
then actually also bob has like but if
you look on the dos instances since
actually bob has also more than actually
fewer than square of K instances
actually there is going to be actually
pair of instances over here some L and L
prime which are exactly the same so so
what actually what Alice is going to do
she is actually going to send over she
is actually going to send over the list
of the indices which she picks the
largest largest distinguish actually
appears the most number of times she
sends over the indices and then then
actually Bob just looks for for a pair L
prime which is actually also the same
they solve he solves actually he saw and
he doesn't actually solve anything he
just outputs the for one of the one of
those things one of us one of the output
Y output 0 and for
for other pair he actually outputs one
and he knows that this is actually going
to be this is going to be one of them is
inconsistent is doubt so so in this in
this case basically the amounts of
communication is like K log and bits or
actually squad of K log n bits roughly
so it's also actually if it's fits this
this communication budget and what's the
error well the error actually comes only
in the case if actually Alice is not
able to find finder index J which
actually which which which would
correspond to one of our strings so
basically the string none of our strings
actually appear in this list but that
has actually constant probability of
occurring so this constant probability
they actually saw it correctly is not
constant they actually solve it and so
they they actually get some small
advantage actually over over this table
2 to the minus K ok situation so they
actually they have error or smaller than
2 to the K so this this shows that
actually you can actually do something
non-trivial for for this problem and the
question is actually how far you can
actually push this so what we show is
that you cannot actually push it too
much so one of our main results actually
is that we basically prove the following
theorem
so which is like our main technical tool
so so we what we are going to show is
that so maybe let me just state the
state what we prove and then let me
explain why is that is it what we need
so so let's take some decimal which is
distribution on string 0 1 to the N and
let's say we take K which is actually
smaller than 1 over 64 times discrepancy
mu of the function f and I will explain
how I explain in a second what I mean by
this then the distribution deterministic
complexity with respect to the measure
mu or to decay to decay of the the
problem elimination on post of this F of
K so this must be at least will go to 1
over discrepancy
mu of off half plus sorry minus a plus
some small small error term walk 1 minus
epsilon times 2 3 minus K so this is our
main technically result and let me
actually try to explain you the meaning
of this or or what's a corollary so what
it says is basically so there is a by
bias principle actually there is a
duality between between actually
performance on on a distribution of data
mystic protocols and randomized
randomized randomized communication
complexity so so in particle actually
randomized communication complexity
actually corresponds to picking picking
the worst worst case measure worst case
distribution on string 0 1 and building
for it deterministic protocol and what
we are saying is that whatever
distribution we take the the the
deterministic complexity the
distributional this this error epsilon
so so that means like if you you allow
error but the error is measured with
respect to the the pairs of inputs and
their error should be at most epsilon so
the deterministic protocol should be
mostly correct except for fraction at
some of it moods then the elimination of
composed of this of earthquake is at
least logarithm of 1 over discrepancy of
F with respect to this me measure - loke
- some small quantities so what this
means is that if you have function which
actually has a very small discrepancy
and you have some distribution for which
it has small discrepancy then you
basically get a good lover bound and
this is actually there are actually
functions for which we which we have
that so so that's actually for example
for inner product so for inner product
what this implies is
if we take any Pollock than the
randomized randomized complexity of
elimination so this is actually for the
original function f so it's oh this is
not bad so so it's in pies for example
the randomized complexity of elimination
of the inner product so if actually they
are trying to solve inner product of
these instances is at least basically
and a half - ok - this - is small small
order terms
so so basically what it says is that for
example for inner product basically the
best you can you can do is basically
pick one of the instances and solve it
as long as K is not not too big this
doesn't contradict that problem because
that per month well there is actually
factor to which we are you mean the
corresponding corresponding complexity
right so for example I get a greater
than function so you get two strings and
you should do they represent integers
and they you should actually decide
which one is actually bigger so for
greater than is the distribution by by
Braverman and mine Steen which actually
has discrepancy like 1 over square of n
so you get basically like half log n
minus log K
okay so this is so this is some of the
conclusion so basically there are
actually many functions for which we
actually know a relationship between
between actually discrepancy and under
communication complexity it's basically
tied so for those function actually do
get pretty much tight results so how do
we actually how do we actually prove
this or how does how does actually how
does this come that is where does it
come from
so it actually comes from so so this
bound actually comes from these bounds
come from actually looking at what the
error actually means and let me actually
try to define what the regularities and
how does it actually way to do it to the
other so so what do we actually if I
have a communication protocol for for F
that does the error actually comes from
so let's actually let's say I have some
I have some letter mystic protocol so
let me actually look on the domestic
protocol and again I assume that that
there is some fixed distribution mu on
the inputs and I'm looking on the terms
the protocols which actually make error
on some inputs and are correct elsewhere
so I have letter mystic communication
protocol which say common gate cbits
communication so now if I look on the
and this is actually for for my original
function f so this is not for
elimination but I have sorry no this is
for for elimination
okay so so I also actually I do consider
actually some major Moo so it's actually
on okay so that is they're actually how
does the error actually come from so
what's so this is my this is all the
usual matrix of the function of whatever
the protocol computes also it has inputs
0 1 to the KN and 0 1 and what better
mistake protocol actually splits usually
the matrix into rectangles and you look
on the on these rectangles and now how
does actually inside of G let's look on
inside of here inch rectangles so we
have they're actually various various
possible K tapas of inputs and each
capable actually if we would just
actually evaluate the function on all
all the corresponding pairs then it
actually gives you various answers so so
I'm going to split this rectangle based
on on Z where Z is basically the output
of all of all the functions so x1 y1 so
Z is equal to F X x1 y1 x2 y2 so I can
split it according to to the output
value according to the output value now
what is actually what is actually error
in this case
so the error in this case is because if
you are outputting some Z if my protocol
is outputting some Z so it's a
deterministic protocol it should output
basically K bits and if it out put some
Z's and what is going to be error in
this case that's going to be exactly the
inputs which actually this rectangle is
outputting Z so then the error are all
the inputs which actually give you give
you Z so that's like this this part R
sub Z where R sub Z are exactly the
inputs which actually met to Z if you
able it this function so this whole
thing is it's a rectangle life I have
like there are some large rectangles
because I have C bits of communication
then the miss is basically the error and
if you actually some some dis error over
all the rectangles then that gives you
the total error of the of the protocol
so how does it how does it actually so
what we can actually show is that you
can actually relate this this total
error actually to discrepancy and let me
actually just in a few remaining minutes
actually explain you how how that's how
that actually works so what we have here
is behavior this rectangle and image end
up actually so there are two possible
scenarios so maybe if there is actually
some value missing in this rectangle and
there would be zero error now the worst
case for us is actually if we're easy
basically all the rectangles are about
the same size so I have here like 2 to
the K different sorry it's not the
rectangle but but these parts which are
is actually partitioning - so the
problem at for us the error will be
large if actually although all the parts
corresponding to various these will be
about the same size so with respect to
measure mu so the problem is actually if
if for all Z the rectangle are the ears
or or the total rectangle are
corresponding to Z if this is going to
be roughly 2 to the minus K the total
measure
you are of the rectangle then so if all
the guys basically will be able to same
size then that gonna teach you that we
were actually going to to make an arrow
on that rectangle and it basically
guarantees you that if you sum over
everything that then you will basically
end up exactly this is the error we are
you are looking for so so it would give
you error which is roughly 2 to the
minus K so the question is actually for
which functions actually you can show
that that whenever you take a rectangle
it's actually going to be balanced
balanced ly split actually into into
various in various outputs and it turns
out that this is actually this this is
closely related to the discrepancy of of
the original function f and since I
don't have much time I cannot tell you
but if let me just say that so we cool
this actually property which is called
regularity so if actually it is true
that for every rectangle where every we
actually split it into into these pieces
are Z then all of them are about the
same size then we call that regularity
and this is actually property which was
which was used and it's actually used
heavily nowadays in in the lifting in
communication complexity for for lifting
and basically you can show that if
function has has low discrepancy and
it's actually going to be irregular and
that's that's a kind of the bottom line
of of the proof so that's a and once
once it's regular then actually you can
kinda argue that it may require section
lot of communication so I guess since
I'm out of time maybe perhaps let me
[Applause]
right so we actually don't know so we
don't have an example where where we
could actually prove distinction between
discrepancy and communication it I mean
we would actually guess that the right
bound is actually that there are no mice
communication complexity is the
communication complexity of single
instance but we cannot rational
beginning
you mean because of this factor and half
and no we don't know any action it will
be actually interesting to basically
like you know kind of close these gaps
or actually find a better upper bound
actually so this is like a very very
very simple upper bound so maybe you can
actually do something what will be
actually interesting is actually to get
get get rid of this lock lock okay so so
basically there is this low K basically
means that like once you have too many
instances then this lower bound doesn't
tell you anything so for example for
elimination
of greater than you basically don't get
anything months once case like say
linear in n about say for square root of
10 you still get something non-trivial
for inner product you you basically get
something nonzero up to basically
exponential K but it's actually
interesting that a it would be
interesting to know what happens
actually if you go with K beyond
actually exponentially right Paul
actually this works only for smoking
more questions
[Applause]